hallo zusammen heute gibt es wieder leckere
noweck schnitten ich weiß ja dass wir alle
gerade bei warmen temperaturen obey kräfte liebt
und insbesondere wenn es schnitten sind und da hab
ich mal so richtig schönes überlegt das werden wir
nicht so denn orange mond orangen mond auf jeden
fall wenn die weitere namensvorschläge treffen
wir die kommentare dann kann ich den titel auch
gerne noch nach euren wünschen ändern auf jeden
fall machen wird dafür jetzt zuallererst einen
pudding putin schnitten pudding schnitten wir auch
eine idee gewesen egal hauptsache es schmeckt also
wir starten jetzt direkt mit dem pudding und dafür
nehmen wir uns also ich stehe zwar am herd aber da
ist noch ausgeschaltet und ich schreibe immer
ganz genauen mengenangaben und nene infobox ich
sage ernst fuchs weil wir das hier noch zum 1 mrk
nein sagst ja so als er selbst das ist die banken
auf jeden fall gebe ich hiermit rein so zum ich
gebe ich speisestärke zucker und 1 eigelb und
verrührt das jetzt erst mal vorab miteinander so
hinzu kommt jetzt noch marmelade dann nämlich von
schäfers frutti orange das original englische
orangenmarmelade und vielleicht erinnert ihr
euch noch an das video mit dem namen köpft liebe
ja auch das lenkrad von jeffers und da nehme ich
einfach gefragt hey möchtest du dem noch mal
ein rezept für uns einfallen lassen und ich hab
doch natürlich klar denn ich mag das total gerne
und es ist ja auch so dass durch eine zutat sich
so die ganze idee aufbaut und ich hatte dieses
mal mit lager und probieren immer gedacht okay
schmeckt sehr fruchtig sehr nach orange passend
dazu mache ich ein pudding geht monat zugleich
gebe ich noch vanille dazu und ich habe das
schon mal vor nicht gebacken backen tut man
sich nicht schon mal vorbereitet und es hat uns
allen sehr gut geschmeckt und passt auch super
gut zum sommer und das einzige was sie jetzt noch
machen müsst genau vanille extrakt nicht vergessen
ist eine gute kombination und also ganze jetzt
nochmal verrühren den herd einschalten und dann
immer dranbleiben immer höheren und sobald es auf
kocht dick dass ein dass sie keine speisestärke
und dann haben eigentlich ein großteil ja schon
geschafft und so ein richtiges bild ritter freute
ich hatte in allen gedeckten pudding direkt
vom herd gezogen und mohn untergerührt danach
einfach nur stehen lassen zwischendurch gern
mal umrühren und zwar 15 minuten damit so ein
bisschen ausdampfen kann es jetzt noch lauwarm
und da gebe ich auch schon die mascarpone mit
dazu dass die letzte zutat für unseren äckern
putting auch einrühren und dann können wir
eigentlich schon an die form gehen und das
ganze schichten so ich habe jetzt die erste
ladung kekse auf dem boden gegeben ich habe
hier auch noch unten drunter ein backpapier
und darunter einen torten retter dann hat er
einfach die perfekte konstruktion und jetzt
geben wir auch noch den lauwarmen pulling darauf
der sollte auch lauwarm sein damit eben die kekse
dadurch ein bisschen einweichen können und auch
die oberen kekse die kommen welche direkt oben
drauf damit sie in der rest sei eben nicht mehr
so knackig bleiben sondern schön weich werden
die schnitten geben wir dann für mindestens drei
stunden in den kühlschrank wenn sie auch noch mal
richtig schön fest und in der zwischenzeit habe
ich die sahne steif geschlagene mit sahne fest
und ein bisschen vanille extrakt und das traue
ich dann später für die deko und jetzt das ist
mir so weit mir ist alles schön abgekühlt ich
nehme jetzt hier nochmal eine backform löser
um mit den bug raum zu entfernen und mir die
schlitten hat auch nicht kaputt zu reifen und
danach der kurier ich mit der vorbereiteten
sahne und ich nehme noch ein paar orangen
stücke mit dazu damit so ein kleiner hinweis
ist was sich quasi in der polin creme versteckt
ich habe passiert jetzt die sind vor allem
auf meinen teller mehr zogen also extra dass
das passt ja ja bist du ein super feiert dieses
trikot hosen fall also ich hab halt den hansa
geholt vielen tasty hatte gesehen dass der keks
supersoft ist der wird auch sofort soft wegen im
warmen pudding war sehr erfrischend ich bin super
froh sein regime nicht direkt erst langsam ein
erfrischend du spinnst du sonst könnten wir süße
her weil der keks hat ja auch schon süße und dem
ganzen ganzen problem nur 100 gramm zucker was
eigentlich fast gar nichts ist also egal was du
mitmachst ja ich konnte alles ist ich liebe montag
dann deswegen kritisch für den 10.10 von seen
erforschung erreichbar ist ein betreiber kuchen
sondern butterkeksen haben genau wo man merkt doch
ein bisschen frucht also das hört ist schon heute
werden die orangenmarmelade drin und dann sehe ich
gerade ein also es ist spannend ob es schmeckt
auch so fruchtig und zusammen mit dem mond mit
der vanille geniale kombination wie du sowas und
kaffee bekommen freuen ja ist mal was anderes
not sind und vor allem hält er sich jetzt im
kühlschrank auch bis zu vier tage aber ich glaube
nicht dass das so lange du hast es keine gelatine
sowas necken dabei kommuniziert das aussehen ist
ultrafast und nacht nur die speisestärke also
unbedingt nachmachen so gerade auch in summe
also ich muss keine angst haben dass williams
oder so das absolut nicht der kann auch wenn
ihr ein buffet habt oder so auf dem tisch der kann
ruhig da zwei drei stunden dann stehen das macht
mir überhaupt nichts aus danke danke schön ist
denn gerne ganz kalt aus dem kühlschrank man ist
ja noch mal extra erfrischend kleiner tipp von mir
wir können uns derzeit seinen kaffee und ich würde
mal sagen abonniert den kanal wenn es nicht schon
längst getan habt dann wieder bestimmt also schon
also ich wünsche euch noch einen wunderschönen
tag und bis zum nächsten mal auf die couch in
chips groß prost wie wir immer nach dem auto
eigentlich beginnt um 17 uhr und dann stehen wir
hier noch in essen waiblingen immer losgeflogen
das war so schlecht dass es schon gut war